our next speaker is Jack Smith and he's
the previous co-founder of bungle which
does in that video ads and has raised 25
million dollars as well as the
co-founder ship the on-demand shipping
company that's raised 20 million dollars
and fun fact Jack Smith's only 25 so
yeah he makes us all feel great
so today Jackson explained how he's been
able to use automation to get a lot of
done very quickly hi guys I was
excited to come down today because
hustling it's not a word that I'd heard
of before coming to America but after I
came to America I felt they really
embodied kind of the philosophy of how I
approach a lot of things and so I wanted
to just talk today about automation or
you could also call it like process
optimization and just kind of a mind
frame of how to think through approach
to some different things about my
background was that I moved to America
three years ago now with my first
startup Vangel and had had the
opportunity to be involved with some
really great companies and so seen
different ways to approach business now
when I'm talking about process
optimization or automation it's really
talking about how can we use kind of
computer power or maybe low-cost labor
to achieve a task faster because at the
end of the day we're all strapped for
time and so the time to use process
optimization for me is when you break
down that something that you want to do
and you can clearly see that there's a
bottleneck because there's no point in
trying to automate something if the
amount of time that you spend automating
it is longer than it would have taken to
do anyway you know but if you can
clearly see alright this is a project
I'm gonna do and this thing is just a
real
the real bottleneck in the process then
what you'd want to look at is how can we
just attack just this bottleneck and so
an example that I want to give and
because it sounds quite technical at the
start but as I said it's just a frame of
mind and it can be applied if you're
just in your personal life doing trying
to get startup off the ground
anything it's the way of thinking
through stuff the example I'm going to
use is recruiting an office manager
because it's something it's one of the
first hires that you maybe do going into
a startup it's something that talked
about on the 500 startups mailing list
just we were discussing it a bit and I
said how we had hired our office manager
fungal people found interesting so I
thought I'd just share with everyone
here if you are a start-up and you want
to recruit your office manager pretty
much what 90% of startup to do is they
just shove it on crash of an ad on
Craigslist and to an applicant this is
what it looks like
like you've just got a stream of just
office manager for start-up office
manager for a really exciting startup
venture back startup blah blah use must
be noise and all that it's going to
result in like shoving an ad on
Craigslist you're just gonna get like
hundreds and hundreds of emails and so a
colleague bottleneck in this process is
well I've got hundreds of emails I've
got to look through so when approaching
this I fought it through in terms of
alright how can we attack that
bottleneck filtering through hundreds
and hundreds of cold emails loads of
this which is not going to be relevant
and when you look at most of the ads on
on Craigslist startups are recruiting
the same kind of attributes for an
office manager they want someone with
good personality good communication
skills and that can follow instruction
how are you going to be filtering those
just based on reading someone's called
email you know that they've got a good
personality doesn't come across an email
so what I did I'm just going to show it
again this is a basic example of
what I'm talking about with automation
or process optimization a basic example
of how I filtered that process what I
used is it's a free tool called um roof
ooh here I just set up a basic form so
just asking the person's name email
address and phone number and you'll see
it's asking for the phone number in this
format
now what we're testing here is can
someone just follow basic instruction
you see I didn't I didn't give out my
email address in the ad so they're not
emailing me they just fill out this
basic form then what happened is I use
this thing called zap ei now this is
really awesome again it's quite basic to
understand it's a bit like if if some
people pearl that it's like if this then
that and so what you do is I chose my
waifu form on the left and a Twilio
account on the right both for these like
we perform it's free Twilio i think i
loaded like $5 or $10 on my account and
Twilio lets you spin up like a new kind
of cell phone number in the cloud it's
not your phone number it's just like a
cloud phone and so why did is every time
that someone filled out that form
every time they filled out that form a
text message would get sent to the phone
number that they entered in the form and
it's a stock message I wrote but because
it says hey name I'm using the name that
they entered in form so they say they
fill out the form and like five minutes
later I'll get a text saying like hey
Jack like thanks so much for applying
for office manager position can you just
check out this link for me when you get
a moment so again I didn't do anything I
just did something like a couple of
minutes to sow this thing it's all
automated but so many people thought
that it was me texting them like you
again because it's a number in the cloud
I wasn't getting loads of spam text back
because I only saw them when I logged in
it's not going to my phone but when I
did login you see people like oh wow
thanks so much for taking the time out
to text me
so you replied so fast etc but again
this is me just filtering for stuff so
I'm like hey can you go to this link and
on this link your it was like a landing
page again I just hacked it together
really fast and I put just embedded a
YouTube video myself and it's me just
talking for like 1 to 2 minutes just
like hey I'm Jack this is my company
bungles very exciting blah blah blah
about me because it's important that I
show that I'm willing to put myself out
there and then I use this again another
tool I'll come back to these tools at
the end so you've got them for efference
but this one's called mail view and what
it is is its embedded next to it so
basically I was saying hey here's me can
you just record me a one to two minute
video of you and person just clicked
record they just record a video and
that's it and this is actually the girl
that we ended up hiring as ahrefs
manager because what it meant is rather
than having these hundreds of emails
from people I could just have a filtered
down not just a few 1 to 2 minute videos
to just flick through you know and just
if we look at what we were judging in
that role it's just in you can't even
compare being able to judge someone's
personality from like an email versus a
one to two minute video like it's
no-brainer you know so what we did here
I don't have a bit that I think is
important is just using Gmail canned
responses is anyone that we rejected I
think it's good to you know send them an
email just saying like look thanks so
much for taking time out to record a
video but we weren't over an account
another candidate because you know if
they've jumped through all your hoops
you might as well one it's only fair to
thank them so these are the tools that I
covered and this was just a short
overview of how we hired an office
manager but when you look at it it was
just filtering by we need we've got a
process
there's a massive bottleneck which is
reviewing loads of candidates
what is the criteria judging their
culture can they follow basic
instruction and so we've set up filters
to filter out those can they fill out a
basic form with their actual phone
number like if they didn't fill out
their phone number they wouldn't have
got the texts they're not going to
proceed can they record a video that's
just basic video you know and so in the
end we only were judging people that
could follow basic instruction and then
with screening are they a good culture
fit and how do they come across in that
video and so hopefully you can apply
that thinking in other areas you work so
this is me I'm gonna soon like this is
my website but then I'm soon gonna
launch a resource called hustle X so
this is why I want to come down because
like hustling is really saying that I'm
passionate about and here I'm just going
to try and collate kind of resources and
tips and stuff from bits that I've
shared with companies I advise etc I was
like well I might as well share that
with everyone so this day I'll be
launching soon thanks a lot guys